streamer Rich Campbell one of the
founding members of content network
otk has been accused of sexual assault
the disturbing allegation was made by
streamer Azalea Lexi who says that the
two had an off and on relationship
before the alleged incident occurred in
2021. Now Rich has resigned from otk and
says that he'll present his version of
events soon meanwhile Azalea Lexi has
said that she's received disturbing
messages as a result of coming forward
and telling her story so what do we know
so far let's take a look
before I get into the video I do need to
warn you this video contains
descriptions of sexual assault sexual
activity fetishes and pregnancy and if
you aren't equipped to deal with that
today I totally understand but now would
be the time to tap out okay let's get on
with the video okay so last Thursday and
Friday streamer Azalea Lexi accused Rich
Campbell who is part of the otk content
network of sexual assault okay so if you
don't know what otk is it's a Content
Network founded by a bunch of streamers
who are friends initially that included
names like asthma gold s fan Ms Kiff and
Rich Campbell but nowadays there have
been many others who have joined otk so
the allegation made by Azalea Lexi
claims that she and Campbell had a
relationship for about four years that
was off and on but by the time of the
alleged incident in 2021 she had decided
that she wasn't going to have a sexual
relationship with Rich Azalea Alexi's
first tweet about the situation was on
third Thursday and seemingly in response
to a video of Campbell's current
girlfriend Mia Malkova explaining that
he has a pregnancy fetish the video was
taken from a recent episode of pillow
talk with Ryan Powell where Malkova
discusses Campbell including his fetish
he's a he is a pregnant fetish he really
wants to get me pregnant
that's kind of hot though he has a what
he wants to get me pregnant Azalea Lexi
immediately followed up that first tweet
with another that said she's sick of
pretending it didn't happen then on
Friday morning she posted a twit longer
with her full account of what happened
along with some screenshots of text
conversations she characterized her
relationship with Rich as anything but
healthy saying quote there were several
times during the four years that he made
it clear that he only viewed me as a
sexual object but when I would confront
him about it I would get love bombed and
gaslit into thinking that he cared about
me and wanted to be with me still they
had a friendship Azalea Lexi said quote
after he lied to me about having a
girlfriend for next standard amount of
time in June of 2021 I didn't speak to
him or see him until he called me asking
to apologize around the end of July
beginning of August I always had a deep
love for rich as a person and that he
wanted to be in my life end quote but
according to her she had moved past the
idea of a sexual relationship with
Campbell and that didn't change when she
was invited to his sub-a-thon in 2021.
she said she declined because she didn't
want to sleep with him she didn't trust
him and she declined another invite in
December 2021 for a similar reason but
in late January 2022 Azalea Lexi said
she ubered to Campbell's building in New
York and the two met in a movie theater
in the building which is seemingly at
least a semi-public space and according
to her account he kept trying to get her
to lie on him by her account quote I
repeatedly said I'm not here to sleep
with you and I do not want that at one
point in the theater he said I think
tonight is the last time I'm ever going
to see you after trying to speak to him
for an hour about our relationship and
the way he treated me he just continued
to deflect and said there's no reason to
talk about it because it makes him feel
bad he said that we couldn't stay in
that room and needed to go up to his
apartment per the apartment rules I said
I don't trust that and he promised me
that was the situation that nothing
would happen and was respecting the
boundary I set according to Azalea Lexi
this is where things really went off the
rails she said that once they got up to
the apartment Campbell began talking
about his pregnancy fetish and started
masturbating in front of her then she
said he kept begging her for sex and
tried to remove her clothes multiple
times she kept saying no and then at the
end he quote rolled me over and put
himself inside me and finished
unprotected end quote Campbell allegedly
told her that she couldn't stay there
but the friend that she was staying with
was already asleep and wasn't answering
her phone so she booked the cheapest
hotel she could find and according to
her she hasn't spoken to Campbell since
I mentioned photos and these seem to
clearly depict a conversation between
Azalea Lexi and Campbell at the
approximate time and date mentioned in
her account these photos also mentioned
the theater in Campbell's building and
he also seems to acknowledge that he
knows she is uncomfortable with being
alone with him in his apartment about
seven hours after Azalea posted her twit
longer otk tweeted that Campbell had
resigned from the org with immediate
effect Campbell then tweeted that he
would share his side of the story once
he had collected his thoughts aspengold
who was also one of the co-founders of
otk and a close friend of Campbell
shared a statement about the situation
on his stream on Saturday I want to say
one thing though before I I go any
farther you are not on our team you are
not helping us you are not doing us any
favors or doing anyone any favors
by calling a girl that comes out and
tells this kind of a story a liar I read
a lot of the comments on Twitter Etc and
I saw a lot of people that were saying
that it wasn't true that she's making
everything up please do not do that you
are not our fan you're not on our side
we are on their side that's why rich is
gone Aspen went on to say that if fans
did these things then they shouldn't
consider themselves fans of asmin or otk
and you can tell he was pretty
distraught about everything that had
happened even choosing to end the stream
early otk is a Content network but it
was also supposed to be a group of
friends that was the idea behind how it
was founded and both asman and Campbell
had hopes for the thing to succeed to
see it end like this is obviously
disturbing for asthma that's why I think
the statement from asman is so critical
if he didn't make a statement about the
fact that you're not on his side for
defending Campbell then we could see all
sorts of other comments directed at
Azalea Lexi trying to discredit her
account and let's not forget that asman
has come under Fire in the past for his
community's actions particularly
brigading frankly I think Osmond gold
has matured a lot since that time and
this is another indication that he's
taking this whole thing very seriously
for Rich
otk was an outlet a way to move on from
blizzard turning their backs on his
casting career it was there for him in
one of his darkest moments now this
isn't the first controversy to Rack otk
if you recall earlier this year mizkiff
was accused of helping to cover up a
sexual assault allegation against his
friend crazy slick at the time he was
placed on leave from otk so that an
independent investigation could be
completed I don't have time to go into
that whole story here but if you want to
learn more you can check out our video
about it from September as of right now
Ms Kiff is still on leave but unlike
that situation it looks like the rich
Campbell one is out of otk's hands at
least for now and it's hard to say
exactly where this goes from here there
were hints in asman's statement that
there's more information we haven't
heard but we haven't heard it and as far
as I'm aware there's no pending case or
anything Azalea Lexi did tweet on Monday
afternoon and it sounds like she's
received some disturbing messages after
posting the twit longer it's sad to hear
this and I hope she's able to find a way
to move past this scary Behavior here's
hoping more people will take Aspen's
advice and forego the harassment
foreign